no no no hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to get wah I'm
trying to talk here wind whooshes
welcome to gaved on givaudan givaudan
you have a duty in it now this is a
horror game where you're lost in the
wilderness alone werewolves monsters and
demons look all around you even in your
own home oh my god you're the monster
and whatever press escape to quit the
game there's no pause for victims ever
press right click on the mouse to zoom
in to enjoy the solo experience even
more play in the dark while wearing
headphones bathed in blood red light
that's explicitly on there the Beast of
Gevaudan this monster that had terror
spread among humans is responsible for
the bloodbath from June 1764 to June
1767 that particular scurbs killed
between 88 and hundred 24 in France
central region of Gevaudan while some
people were thinking about a wild
creature Mende Bishop Gabriel Florent of
Choi's reboot crow sent a call for
prayers and repentance that statement
would remain known as the Bishop of
Mende decree all the priests of the do
cease warned all the believers the
Bishop tells the story of the beast that
was sent on earth by God to punish the
sinners historians also mention the
possibility that the monster might have
actually been a serial killer however no
solid proof back of that theory for so
long as the Beast does not know you if
you are pure and hold your faith you can
stare into those to curse at pearls born
in the fiery abyss and survive but as
the Beast learns your sentence sins
because it's inexorable approach sliding
closer than you dare imagine even in
nightmare and when finally it can gaze
into the depths of your soul you must
flee for he who keeps an open ear its
appearance shall always be revealed and
for he who keeps an open heart its
presence shall always be felt he who
flings himself away must always carry
himself ready and equipped to do so at
any moment ramblings of a [ __ ] who
claim to have seen the Beast 1765 was
that tram me o my dear Ferdinand you
have accomplished your task in the
forest most excellently for that I thank
you and as a small token of my roared I
have a letter for you you left for you a
key along the indications concerning
your sleeping
mints at milestone 57 endeavored to fall
the list milestones and you shall not be
led astray at recive miss himself are
you well your devoted patron Charles
okay go to my press X to know how ah
okay so that was a hint on the gameplay
that were that were that war okay why am
I here you left me a key but - what did
I get a spooky mansion at the top of the
hill I'm okay with that so long as I
don't get killed by the monster of
Gevaudan I don't like that 32 what does
that mean hey well by [ __ ] me who did
that who did that where and why what is
32 mean who's be Wuan who's be wombling
I see you over there
okay I'm going for it like this I don't
like this at all why 6 what is 6 mean is
it the number of the beast I go hey whoa
big four day whoa wait whoa wait whoa no
no no I got what are you doing what are
you doing I didn't do that yeah that's
right you get gone yeah I spotted you
yeah I saw did you real good you think
you didn't saw me where's the little
marker x' i got one other here i know
i'm supposed to look for the litt god
it's certainly not lit out here ah is
that a litte more kur alright imma find
me my way five
okay again I don't see the lip no not
that way it's just impossible to see
whoa I jump high like a mad hops okay
hey oh hey I don't see anybody hey I see
you
I've got no sin in my heart yeah that's
right you [ __ ] right off you [ __ ] right
off I don't know where the other marker
is I am lost babe in the woods oh it's
dark over here
oh it's dark on this side of the
mountain oh where is it where is it
where is it I don't understand
[ __ ] yeah yeah the choir of the Damned
has started to sing so I'm assuming that
means I'm fob what is that is that a
wall just some kind of building that is
obviously a constructed wall whoa are we
in the north this game of thrones not
made of ice but I'll take it
oh boy oh yeah yeah hey hey buddy
no no hey no hey you wibblewobble your
way out of here okay so maybe from the
direction that he came from is where I'm
supposed to go I don't know if that's
true or not but that's you know that's
kind of something oh maybe the five
means that's milestone number five what
is this is this one I've been to already
or is this a new one okay so this is
milestone number six so I got a find
number 32 maybe I just need to wander
into the woods and find it because maybe
there might not be a direction to these
things maybe it's just wherever I go
could be you never know with that ah
that might be number five oh this is
number five okay
all right I'm getting it I'm getting me
hey [ __ ] god damn it stop doing that
every single time I turn my back oh you
go and get closer go see the evil in my
eyes so I got your number I know what
you're doing I'm gonna follow you back
to your home see how you like it maybe
this key is to your place and I'm
evicting you from your house and maybe
you're not gonna be too happy when I
come out and kick you on your ass and
then kick you in your ass
and then kick your ass off and then kick
it all around town I don't know I am
lost oh yeah you was out sooner than it
was before where'd you come from
where is he oh hey hey Bigfoot hey Kevon
in man
Givaudan dude get off get off me get off
my back
get off my dick like I'm okay with the
whole wandering in the woods horror game
trope because this is at least a
different mechanic than say a Slenderman
coming up behind me but this guy I have
a funky feeling that he's getting closer
and closer and closer and every time he
comes by you want to go bro you want to
go bro so I wasn't supposed to run
towards the monsters is what it is all
right let's try this again
so there's a consuming there's a this
market behind me number four
[Music]
so this doesn't really help me but maybe
if I steer really intensely into the
monsters eyes maybe then maybe then it
was so scared of me of my not sinning
nature of my total innocence inside my
heart which I have I definitely have
three I don't wanna I don't want to
count down maybe if I could see
something if I get to the top of this
hill
I've got no bearing on the land he can't
see far enough to be able to get any
discernible features out of the
landscape so it's it's gonna be me on my
wits
my survival wits ah those the Stars or
is that snow can't quite tell I think
it's snow all right she's got to be ah I
think that's yeah that's a glow okay
all right all right all right to God I'm
counting down to one I don't want to go
to one I need to go to two of there's
another or I need to go to 57 which is
like miles away from these ones hey hey
buddy hey I see you there staring at you
real good oh yeah okay yeah I better not
think any impure thoughts oh boy boy
that Givaudan monster sure out of sex
doesn't seem like there's anything over
here there's that wall again I guess
that's just the pen that I'm in to
wrassle me in but I seem to have gone
the complete wrong direction I I haven't
exactly been counting up the way I need
to count am i I'm about to hit the I hit
the ceiling I hit the ceiling of the
world
I found the roof mom I found it I found
the roof hey you'll never be able to
find me in here alright but at least I'm
at the highest point I suppose that's so
weird
the roof of the world did they not
expect I did not expect anybody to come
up here I see you
[Music]
Hey how's it going whoa whoa okay found
the edge of the world well what happens
if I fall off I found the edge of the
world I guess they didn't expect anybody
to go over there but I sure did who it
is I am what's gonna happen if I just
stay down here forever all am I gonna
all right let's actually try to follow
the trails and use the zooming to be
able to guide us where we need to go cuz
this is 32 but why is this 132 there's
another light over there but I'm gonna
try to go over this way and see like
towards the moon because that way just
counted to six and maybe it's like a
circle or something
ah I see another one okay all right what
number is this gonna be and why do I
need to find a key at a marker 26 okay
that's not quite whatever what is that
what is that
please tell me that's just a tree what
am i it looks like a cliff face whoa it
is no it's a hill it's a rock it's a
rock we can ride this bad boy all to our
destination Oh perfect
is there just a rock jutting out from
the landscape here this all right god
damn it I was marveling this rock gonna
leave me alone hey I got no say whoa
that was too close for my comfort
I got no sin in my heart I'm just
looking at this rock I ain't lusting
after this rock okay
you leave me to my innocence and then
we'll all get along fine 24 yeah that's
the counting's weird on these I think I
just got to find him like randomly by
happenstance is what's this one
23 okay counting down again I've gotten
farther by just following the the moon
more rocks god those are some sexy rocks
nope the Givaudan beast doesn't hear me
talking about those rocks that way the
curves on those rocks 22 okay I'm
counting down then why was 32 right in
the middle of this place it must be a
bunch of criss crossing paths that that
must be what it'd be and I just so
happened to go the wrong way and find an
edge or I didn't need to find 150 wait a
minute nope just got the 50 somehow hi
I got the 50 don't get me wrong it ain't
69 you leave me be I see you peeping I
see you peeping behind that Boosh
you get over here I got places to be
people to see markers to lead me to
safety I can get where I need to get
then 51 okay we're counting up so we
might be close all right all right all
right let's get it oh I see you down
there so I'm getting closer that means
maybe not unless it jumps another number
again which is what is one to do not 52
okay so we're getting closer
[Music]
the music's changing which is awfully
nice like that it's the monster gonna
change 53 53 four more to go get a key
what it do I don't know okay weird I
know where are you well I see you see
you people know yeah that's right okay
all right it's not to be
over the I it is okay my faith has kept
me going and the woods are dying over
here which good sign I guess 54 closer
must just be that way right it would be
down this valley it seems like something
that they would be leading me into the
denser yeah the denser forest lead me to
my Victoria all right 57 just do more to
go don't kill me I think I see something
over there nope I lied as it's a trick
of the mind I'm I just followed the
woods yeah two more I don't know what
I'm gonna find it is number 57 but I'm
sure I'm excited for it get 56 means
fifty-seven muscle to be continuing down
this way right hey where were you
well I see you in there alright I'll be
beeping yeah no no no no no no no no no
unfortunately I'm actually all out of
time I thought I was gonna find it right
then and there I'm out of time today I
gotta go
[ __ ] all right I might pick this up
again just to see what the mystery is or
I don't know maybe like slap it onto
another video just so I can see because
I'm curious I want to know the game is
good few flaws here and there but I want
to know why am I going for this key so
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching sorry around that time but
I will try to get this in another video
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]